wir sind so dicht dran an der entdeckung
von aliens auch die nasa geht davon aus
dass wir außerirdisches leben in den
nächsten jahren entdecken werden aber
wie realistisch ist das wirklich und
warum ist sich die nasa da so sicher
klicks hansa im future mit den indizien
für die entdeckung von außerirdischen
leben in der spektakulären edition
zukunft rowohlt hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende wissenschaft ihres
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
ging es herzlich willkommen in der
edition zukunft robert beschäftigen wir
uns mit den spannendsten und
spektakulärsten entwicklung die laut der
wissenschaft tatsächlich möglich sind
und zwar mit themen aus meinem neuen
buch per aufzug in den weltraum
erschienen im rowohlt verlag und in
diesem buch geht es um unsere zukunft um
realistische szenarien wie sie aussehen
könnte wissenschaftlich begründet wer
also einen blick in die zukunft werfen
möchte der sollte hier auf den link zum
buch unterm klicken
immer wieder habe ich den eindruck dass
wir von der entdeckung von aliens nur
einmal entfernt sind es müsste
eigentlich schon passiert sein oder eben
morgen oder übermorgen geschehen gerade
war es wieder soweit als das molekül
mono phosphat in der atmosphäre der
venus gefunden wurde
das hier auf der erde nur von lebenden
organismen erzeugt werden kann manchmal
drauf ich mir wirklich die haare und es
spricht ja wirklich alles dafür
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
der nasa gehen davon aus dass wir in den
nächsten 20 jahren außerirdisches leben
entdecken werden während es vor wenigen
jahrzehnten noch überhaupt nicht klar
war ob es überhaupt planeten außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems gibt sind
inzwischen tausende entdeckt worden und
auf einigen hundert könnte leben
tatsächlich möglich sein
diese planeten liegen in der habitablen
zone um einen stern also in dem bereich
in dem angenommen wird dass die
bedingungen für die entstehung von leben
gegeben seien könnten dort ist es so
waren das wasser flüssig wäre aber auch
nicht so heiß dass es verdampfen würde
ein entscheidendes kriterium denn leben
ohne wasser wurde bisher noch nicht
entdeckt es spricht zurzeit noch alles
dafür dass nur in einer solchen umgebung
ehrt ähnliches leben entstehen kann doch
bisher konnte auf diesen exoplaneten
kein leben nachgewiesen werden die
satelliten und teleskope die wir im
moment so verfügt
zu haben sind dazu auch nicht geeignet
erst das james webb weltraumteleskop ein
gemeinschaftsprojekt von nasa esa und
der kanadischen csu soll in der lage
sein die atmosphäre eines exoplaneten
festzustellen und zu analysieren
dies wird möglich sein wenn licht seines
sterns durch die atmosphäre des
exoplaneten strahlt anhand des
absorbierten licht soll dieses teleskop
in der lage sein ihre zusammensetzung
also die zusammensetzung der atmosphäre
zu bestimmen leider verschiebt sich der
start des weltraumteleskops immer wieder
nach hinten aktuell ist nächstes jahr
2021 angesagt im oktober soll es soweit
sein
doch auch innerhalb unseres
sonnensystems scheint die entdeckung von
außerirdischen lebensformen oder
zumindest ihren spuren zum greifen nah
zu sein zum beispiel hat die raumsonde
cassini 2017 auf dem saturnmond
enceladus geysire entdeckt der mission
verlauf wurde daraufhin geändert und
cassini durchflog diese geysire um ihre
zusammensetzung zu untersuchen
die ergebnisse waren spektakulär
messungen durch cassini ergaben eine
vielfalt organischer verbindungen unter
der oberfläche des mondes und sie
deuteten auf flüssiges wasser hin sie
enthielten alles was für leben notwendig
wäre
allerdings waren die messinstrumente
nicht dazu geeignet leben selbst zu
finden schon bei früheren vorbeiflügen
hatte die sonde festgestellt dass
enceladus vollständig mit hochreinem
wasser eis überzogen ist ein magnetfeld
und eine atmosphäre besitzt die sich
vermutlich vulkanischer aktivität zu
verdanken ist
auch auf dem mars gibt es deutliche
anzeichen von leben immer wieder wird
mit den verschiedenen sonden und
messinstrumenten des treibhausgas methan
festgestellt woher kommt es wir kennen
methan als ein gas das vor allem beim
stoffwechsel von lebewesen entsteht auf
der erde zum beispiel produzieren und
pflanzen und tiere ein einziges rind
gibt täglich allein mehrere hundert
liter methan ab wer oder was scheidet es
also auf dem mars aus oder dem
saturnmond titan der eine dichte
atmosphäre mit viel methan enthält
ungeklärte fragen schon auf der erde
weiß man nicht genug darüber wie sich
die methan vorkommen in der natur
regulieren
eine hypothese macht es dabei sogar sehr
wahrscheinlich dass es überall wo es
leben geben kann auch leben existiert
laut der sogenannten space beim
hypothese oder auf deutsch punch per me
hypothese kam das irdische leben vor
langer zeit aus dem weltall das
verständnis hier
es gibt mikroorganismen die als spermien
fungieren und planeten wie die erde oder
ebenmaß enceladus usw befruchten
zum beispiel dass bärtierchen ist ein
bemerkenswerter kandidat es ist in der
lage komplett auszutrocknen und in eine
tote stare zu verfallen die sogenannte
tönchen phase es ist quasi tot aber doch
am leben irgendwie und trotz vakuum
kosmischer strahlung und viele mehr
kommen die bärte ich ihnen dann in
kontakt mit wasser werden die meisten
von ihnen wieder belebt und setzten
ihren lebenszyklus von drei monaten bis
zu zweieinhalb jahren fort sie stehen
quasi wieder von den toten auf zurück zu
den exoplaneten sind wir eigentlich auf
die entdeckung von leben außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems und den kontakt
damit vorbereitet wohl eher schlecht die
mehrheit der menschen und der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
verweigern die erkenntnis dass diese
möglichkeit tatsächlich existiert obwohl
die entwicklung der letzten jahre immer
mehr in diese richtung deuten wenn wir
schon an immer mehr plätzen in unserem
eigenen sonnensystem bedingungen und
spuren finden die leben ermöglichen
könnten müssen uns wahrscheinlich mit
der vorstellung anfreunden das leben
keine ausnahme sondern vielleicht der
normalfall im weltall ist und wenn das
so ist so bedeutet dies dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit hoch ist leben oder
spuren davon zu entdecken
nachdem im september 2017 das erste
interstellare objekt auf der reise durch
unser sonnensystem entdeckt wurde
stellte professor im loeb 2018 die these
auf dass es sich dabei um ein objekt
handeln könnte das von einer
außerirdischen zivilisation stammt eine
alien sonne oder ein teil von ihr in der
wissenschafts interessierten gemeinde
brach ein glaubenskrieg aus lopez nicht
irgendwer er leitet die abteilung
astronomie an der renommierten harvard
university ist damit einer der
wichtigsten
astrophysiker weltweit allerdings ist er
auch mitglied der breakthrough starship
initiative die ihrerseits eine mini
sonde mit einem sonnensegel zu unserem
benachbarten sternensystem alpha
centauri schicken will seine forschung
ist insofern nicht frei von eigenen
interessen
indessen sind seine argumente nicht so
einfach von der hand zu weisen wir haben
ihn ja dazu ausführlich interviewt das
interview ist ja auch unter mir das
objekt und das es geht ist dem oktober
2017 durch das passt das teleskop auf
hawaii entdeckt worden als es schon an
der sonne vorbei geflogen und auf dem
weg aus dem sonnensystem erneut in den
interstellaren raum war es bekam den
namen die einst interstellare objekt 1
humor zuvor hatte es in einer entfernung
von etwa 24 millionen kilometern die
erde passiert weitere beobachtungen
ergaben dass sie einst zigarren vermisst
eine feste oberfläche hat und ungefähr
aus der gegend der wega stammen könnte
inzwischen ist es als komet eingestuft
worden obwohl es keinen
charakteristischen schweiz hat und auch
keine ausgasung zeigt genauso gut ist
möglich dass es gar kein komet war die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass durchflog ist
eines solchen objektes wäre es
natürlichen ursprungs ist extrem
geringen oder es müsste viel mehr
solcher objekte geben als bisher
angenommen wurde
zudem ist mit dem fliegenden körper
etwas extrem bemerkenswertes passieren
beim vorbeiflug an unserer sonne wurde
es durch den strahlungsdruck
beschleunigt laut lips berechnungen
müsste das objekt weniger als einen
millimeter dick sein und die masse von
etwa 100 mal 20 metern haben und auch
eine neue studie spricht dafür dass es
ziemlich genau diese masse hat aus
meiner sicht lässt das eigentlich nur
den schluss zu es ist künstlicher natur
hergestellt von einer außerirdischen
intelligenten spezies budgetierte dazu
in dem interview mit mir aber kann und
dolls helden sherlock holmes wenn man
das unmögliche ausgeschlossen hat muss
das was übrig bleibt die wahrheit sein
so unwahrscheinlich sie auch klingen mag
auch wenn er sich in seinem interview
sehr zurückhaltend gibt die möglichkeit
einer alien sonde ist nicht nur nicht
auszuschließen sondern sogar
wahrscheinlich genau hier in dessen
scheiden sich die geister aber alle
indizien und die entdeckung der letzten
jahre sprechen eine klare sprache so
oder so werden wir den nächsten
ein außerirdisches leben oder zumindest
spuren davon entdecken
dieses und viele andere themen aus
unserer zukunft findet ihr in meinem
neuen buch per aufzug in den weltraum
das gibt es direkt hier einfach
draufklicken oder ihr geht zur nächsten
buchhandlungen und unterstützt den
buchhandel in diesen schweren zeiten
vielen dank dass er dabei seid und
klicks und platz vier geht es übrigens
zum interview mit apple lockt bis dann
dran